rescue teams are working around the
clock recovering bodies and searching
for those still missing
thousands have been displaced losing all
of their belongings
heavy rainfall began on wednesday in
brazil's northeastern state of penambuco
flooding streets and triggering
mudslides
entire houses collapsed
with the force of the water while
desperate neighbors help firefighters
dig up their loved ones under the rubble
this man lost his sister
the search parties found my sister's
body there this evening
they found her and four other bodies
they're still looking for my
brother-in-law
this is the fourth major flooding event
in five months in brazil
in february more than 200 people died
after torrential rains hit the city of
petropolis 80 kilometers from rio de
janeiro
meteorologists say a phenomenon called
la nina which cools down the pacific
ocean waters helps explain the excessive
rains in pernambuco and other parts of
northeastern brazil
there is no doubt that climate change
and the rise of temperature in the
atlantic ocean are also responsible for
these extremes cold weather hot weather
droughts and rainfalls they've all
become more severe besides bad weather
poor urban planning in low-income
neighborhoods in many brazilian cities
is also responsible for the number of
deaths and the mudslides
parts of slums built on hills were swept
away by water and mud
this woman saw her neighbor's house
collapsed
the whole family died the father the two
children the wife all died
president jai bolsonaro toured the
region in a helicopter but was told it
was unsafe to land
we express our sorrows to the relatives
our main objective is to come for the
relatives and to help the
population bolsonaro said the government
can make available 200 000 u.s dollars
to help victims of natural disasters
meteorologists expect more rain in
bernaboko and neighboring states in the
coming days
the danger of more mudslides in the
regions is far from over
mauna kea
al-jazeera rio de janeiro